on vous emmène à présent à la caserne
des pompiers de tour Nord à la rencontre
de travailleurs pas comme les autres les
malinois ces chiens très intelligents
contribu à sauver des vies comme tout
pompier et eux aussi ont droit à une
retraite Yago 11 ans quitte donc le
terrain au profit de syika la nouvelle
recrue le zoom sur l'activité de ces
héros à quatre pattes avec Faustine
luno c'est avec une joie manifeste que
Yago vient rendre visite à ses collègues
depuis 2015 il faisait équipe avec son
Pier auin de la caserne de tour nord un
duo de choc qui se sépare du moins sur
le terrain car le malinois de 11 ans
vient de prendre sa retraite ça fait 8
ans et demi qu'il est opérationnel chez
les pompiers il a fait de nombreuses
interventions et tout mais pour le
bien-être de l'animal il commence à être
vieux les entraînements c'est de plus en
plus dur il commence à avoir des petits
des petits problèmes de santé on va dire
donc il vaut mieux l'arrêter pour qu'il
finisse sa vie tranquillement à la
maison au Chud la fin d'une belle ri
puisqueag a participé à près d'une
centaine d'interventions son rôle
localiser des personnes égarées des
victimes soudé des Combres ou tomberé
dans l'eau démonstration donc là on va
cacher une victime dans la remise
et le chien il va il va la trouver donc
dès qu'il va trouver fait il Vayer pour
prévenir le matre et dès qu'ilouvre tu
la récompense d'accord fait nos chiens
sont conditionnés dès qu'il pent une
tenue comme ça ils savent qu'il faut
travailler et là juste un
ordre cherche à
[Musique]
bois dressage la première chose à
apprendre à un chien c'est l'amour de la
victime il faut vraiment que le chien
soit amoureux de la victime pour le
rechercher partout et qui dit victime
qui dit récompense et il a retrouvé 4 C
personnes c'est très bien l'équipe
syotechnique de Touren compte au total
six chiens qui interviennent 20 à 30
fois par an pour rechercher des
personnes disparu une remplaçante est
d'ailleurs déjà toute trouvée pour Yago
sa petite sœur saika qui vient d'achever
ses 2 ans de formation malgré que ça
soit un petit caractère bien trempé
a du gros potentiel et je pense que
largement les capacités pour remplacer
Yago et tout et j'ai aucune inquiétude
dessus ouis c'est bien le c'est bien ma
fille
fille excellente lors des exercices
saika va bientôt travailler en condition
réell puisqu'elle vient de prendre ses
fonctions au 1er janvier quant à Yago il
va pouvoir désormais profiter d'un repos
bien mérité mais sans jamais vraiment
s'éloigner de la caserne puisqu'il
continuera d'y accompagner son maître
tous les
jours